after three long years in his Mane shed
david cameron's doorstopper
/ memoirs is it last upon us for my
money I think it's been worth the wait
so I may not be giving it to every
member of the family for Christmas it's
important that we hear his version of
events the inside story of his
renegotiation with the EU and the
campaign to keep this country in the
bloc that ultimately failed and his
relationships with all the main actors a
tender thing that political memoirs
often aren't worth the paper they are
written on and far too long and
self-justifying okay it may be too much
too late but this is an overdue mayor
Cooper that has melted my stone-cold
heart just a little okay well most of it
didn't melt my heart the bit about his
son Ivan obviously is heart-rending
terribly Toby said however for me the
rest of it it reads like an apology to
all his remaining mates like all that
apologize enough well God I think it
reads like an apology was have made a
path like all remainders in the
political class he's ashamed of the
president vote at ago he's ashamed of
the seventeen point four million who
voted Briggs it to me this book about is
about him settling old scores and he's
using it to excuse his part in the chaos
that is now happening and and and he had
he done his job propias Prime Minister
had he squeezed more concessions out of
the EU when he went over then promises
that he would we wouldn't had the
referendum in the first place
and I also think it's pretty low of a
past prime minister who ran away from
the challenge of brexit to be trashing
the current prime minister who was
busting his guts to make it happen and
and I just I think you know the talk
about about Boris and about go of being
disloyal to him is stupid it wasn't
about him they did what they thought was
best for this country well hey look
go he thought Gove had said he would
join the remain side of cabinet he said
therefore go blows LaLanne Michael Gove
who as it were radicalizing Boris
Johnson yes both of them got radicalized
the country and got them over the line
and we are where we are but he says it
was just how we go through lots to say
ok so Nick spent a lot of time with with
the former prime minister can I turn to
Nick and I just I mean Churchill said
history is going to be kind to me
because I intend to write it you partly
agree with Carroll that he's having to
revise history in order to flatter
himself I agree with you and yes I did I
spent 45 minutes interviewing him and
got in and I think it's very good as
someone that he regularly stretches you
at tennis as he does one of your
brothers and Joe is the only one in your
family who can play tennis that's David
chemistry I don't know I think he comes
out of it very well I think the what's
interesting is he if we come to the
Michael Gove issue he's he's hoping he
wants to build the bridges I'm surprised
I don't think he should really new
Michael Gove that well because I wasn't
that surprised when it came to it but he
actually wasn't leave but shouldn't we
be celebrating the fact that something
as crucial as that politicians actually
felt they could go with their heart and
rather than what they should be party
and that's what I sort of utility of the
political memoir as a genre how useful
is it are they self-serving or otherwise
I know Greg's written one but you're
desperate to come in current well I
think that I admire the way that he has
been so frank and reflective he's
blatantly said I failed yes and one of
my favorite sayings is good judgment
comes from experience and experience
comes from bad judgment and this book is
full of the mistakes that he's made and
one of the biggest mistakes by the way
that he's admitted to which I've always
said brexit would never have happened
had it not been for your brother and
Michael Gove going for leave if that
hadn't happened if they hadn't let David
Cameron John then we would not be in the
position we've been in for the last
three and half years and that is that's
fact as far as I as this sage elder on
this show this on this edition anyway
you've written your own memoir how
useful is this to the historians of the
future or how partial is it we are all
partial anybody who writes an
autobiography is partial of course I'm
it's got to be it's you it's your
explanation for why you did certain
things I don't think I mean I think it
doesn't save him really I mean history
was just as Blair is now seems about the
Iraq law he won't be seen about the
referendum and actually sadly some of
the good things he did will be forgotten
just as some of the good things that
bled you will be forgotten because they
did something so dramatic
there's an interesting I mean coming out
now this particular time obviously
wasn't planned it was planned it would
come out after we'd left it's quite soon
advisee who was you know the arts
minister now an independent MP one of
the ones that was thrown out but was it
was an old Etonian like David knew it
and it I was there yeah he's quite
interesting to hear why he what what
what the counties at the moment I guess
you could say that the vows silence
might be a better strategy but he has
kept quiet but unfortunately his memoirs
are being published so there's nothing
he can do really people are going to
want to interview him and talk to him
and there inevitably going to ask about
the current state of politics of course
he planned to publish his memoirs after
bricks it was in theory going to be
delivered in March so but they have
bizarrely landed right in the middle of
the biggest political turmoil we've seen
yet I mean I think that's it I don't
think he planned to be in the middle to
become such a central character the
interviews I've heard him this week I
mean what is interesting is George
Osborne who was really a pushing him not
students a referendum to really pushing
him to attack Boris Johnson and go and
he wouldn't do it and I want to ask you
that sure cause one of the most
interesting things that came out when I
spoke with him is that he wishes he
played dirtier and they had cartoons
where your brother's seen in Nigel
Farage's pocket and he vetoed that and
he vetoed others like that do you think
it should have been a dirty or fight
from the remain site I think it should
have been unless in weirdly it were
not dirty but it was only negative and
what I think how the remained campaign
Feld was it never said what has the EU
done for us it left everybody thinking
the EU was just busybodies they were
trying to ratchet us towards federalism
and so on and so the positives of the
membership were never explored and he
never was a great advocate for that and
that I think he felt he did this for
money this was kind of a self sold on
giving his 800 that's not what I heard
it was no no no it was anything over the
advance I was going to tell well let me
say that I was privileged to have
interacted worked with him particularly
to do with India and I found him a
really decent really well-meaning and a
really capable individual available
prime minister it's just ashamed forever
now this is the other point there's a
tweet 30-footer there's a tweet that he
put out where he said for three years
I've kept relatively quiet about
politics but I think it's right former
PM's write their memoirs to explain what
they did and why for the record is out
on Thursday so he did run away now what
would have happened if he'd stayed on
what would have happened if Boris had
become Prime Minister
then instead of Teresa who did exactly
what he probably would have done which
would try to not make it happen but you
can't you can't be prime minister of a
country in them the biggest challenge to
hit your country comes you run away from
it and then criticizing the current
prime minister for the way he's handling
it in a dozen or so years when the
current prime minister writes his book
what's going to be the bombshell
revelation in bozos book eight hundred
thousand pounds in my back pocket please
Nick do you think you'd be remembered
world by history I don't I think history
will remember I think he'll go down as a
man who didn't know his part he didn't
know his country and didn't know to move
on that might be true but I don't think
is fair I can't respect you I like but I
thought he did quite a good job in
certain things I
he just made a mistake on the referendum
which he owns up to and he has admitted
to his mistakes and I give him full
credit for that